and we have some breaking news this
morning a Swedish Court has just handed
down a verdict in the assault case
against American rapper ASAP rocky the
court found the rapper guilty of assault
but gave him a suspended sentence the
rapper whose ririn a real name is Rakim
Mayer's was accused of assaulting a man
during a fight in the streets of
Stockholm back in June rocky says he was
just defending himself after two men
followed his entourage and one of them
picked a fight with his bodyguards he
was arrested and held behind bars
because he was considered a flight risk
earlier this month he was set free and
returned to the US following the end of
his trial rocky was not present for this
verdict that's interesting news so he's
found guilty but they said he can remain
free yeah a suspended sentence those
times that he already served he's been
served I think it's about 30 days yeah
it feels like a fairly diplomatic
verdict if you will yeah yeah so it's so
confusing cuz the videotape clearly
showed him saying look we don't want any
trouble with you guys just please just
leave us alone is very that's very
interesting case no